you know I I just have to wonder if
there was an executive at Sony that saw
my video on the Kraven the hunter movie
and me saying that this was crazy and
smell like desperation and they just
went hold my beer so we're gonna talk
about Sony again for the second time in
as many weeks because holy rap the I was
getting slightly nervous when the Kraven
the hunter news broke last week that
Sony was not learning from its past
mistakes or from the mistakes that
Warner Brothers had made in and trying
to build you know the DCE you now I know
they're not paying attention to the
mistakes that have been made now I'm not
taking that as a fact at this point so
let's see if I can even remember all
this first of all background obviously
we have the venom movie coming out later
this year and that's a finished film and
I think that is by far their best shot
at getting decent returns out of all
these ancillary spider-man things I'm
kind of putting that separate from into
the spider verse because as an animated
film the kind that has a completely
different set of expectations heaped on
it in the first place but we've got
those two coming out this year now what
had already been announcing was in some
degree of development is a morbius film
Morbius the living vampire that
currently has Jared Leto attached to
star there had been previously a movie
called silver and black which was going
to be team up between the Spider Men
supporting characters silver sable and
black cat that got taken off the
schedule would be sometime was that it
wasn't gonna happen anymore and then
there was the crate for the hunter thing
getting announced well so first of all
that silver and black project it did get
taken off the schedule
but it's because instead of making one
movie where these two characters team up
they're not planning on making two
movies they usually get a solo film okay
and then move
from that then there was this one I had
to look up now understand I'm a
spider-man fan I'm not like huge over
the top I don't I'm not reading the
comic comics I actually have a red
spider my comics in a while it's not
because I quit them I just I don't
really read monthly comics at all
anymore I haven't for years but I I do
keep up with what's going on with
spider-man then there's plenty of
characters who have only made a couple
of appearances that like I see the name
ago oh yeah I know what their deal is I
had never heard of this character it's a
character by the name of jackpot and I
tried asking around in a few different
places
who the heck this person is between that
looking at the Wikipedia the standard
answer seems to be well it's not Mary
Jane so so far as I understand it
there's a relatively recent character
less than a decade old I think or maybe
about that that long which you know you
need to realize these comics books have
been going on 60 years plus so that's
pretty short so she is some sort of
masked female vigilante and at the time
she was introduced it was teased and
hinted that it was actually Mary Jane
Spidey's I don't know what they are now
they were married and then they made a
deal with the devil and it was really
really really really stupid but in any
case that it was pushed and hinted that
it was gonna be her until it was real
that it wasn't and I guess whoever they
were revealed I don't know if it would
just was not anybody at all or just
somebody nobody cared about but it's to
the point that like I asked whose
jackpot the answer I get is not Mary
Jane that seems to be the only thing
anybody remembers about her why would
you make a movie about this character
for the reason I said they would make a
craven movie Sony is desperate for a
stable at least biannual if not annual
franchise that they can
found on to be profitable because they
really don't have one not one that's
truly legitimately reliable and the
desperation coming off this company is
in sane and it gets worse because if
there's one thing that has been I'm not
gonna say necessarily the saving grace
but I know that I've seen brought up as
like here's why I'm excited for the
venom movie since it was first announced
it was the fact that Sony made clear its
intention to release an r-rated bill
word is now that might not happen and
they may actually cut it to a pg-13 now
let me be the first to say that mmm I'm
gonna say 99 times out of 100 when a
film is cut down for the purposes of
getting a gentler rating that almost
never breaks makes or breaks the film it
might make it a little bit better or a
little bit worse but if there are things
that are good about the film they should
they you know generally will work
whether it's are or not if there are
things that are wrong with the film they
will sink it whether it's are or not so
me personally I don't have a big state
where I'm like you betrayed us you
promised us an r-rated movie but the
thing is I know there's a lot of people
out there who will think that and I know
that there's been a fair amount of the
curiosity and interest in this was tied
to the fact that it was gonna be our
rated and Sony has been talking up how
this was gonna be our rated since it was
first announced so this comes across as
II like the most desperate move that
they could possibly make and I don't get
it because I don't know what Venom's
tracking right now but I think they have
a decent shot with this thing and now
they're just to steal a British Turner
phrase there they're overwriting the
pudding they just won't leave it alone
they just won't let it sell itself and
let it be
they just keep
doing more stuff they keep tinkering and
they keep building more and more and
more additional stuff apparently
somebody tweeted this at me this there's
a name for it the Sony universe of
Marvel characters soon oh god it's that
I'm not gonna say I had much faith in
Sony I didn't but I had up until now a
tiny monochrome of hope that maybe just
maybe they would wait and see the
returns on venom before they dig a huge
freaking hole and just mortgage their
next few years of blockbuster films and
into this pit but they seem to have done
that they they need venom to not just be
a hit to be a big hit and I don't know
if it will be and the other thing is
whatever venom makes it's gonna be more
than any of these other projects I still
say the only one that's got like on
concept the only one that could carry
something would be Morbius but I don't
know if people are I don't know if
vampires are still a thing right now I
feel like the vampire phase kind of
wrapped up the latest cycle of that but
I don't know I think that might have had
a decent shot but all the rest of this
Kraven the hunter silver and black
jackpot to say that nobody asked for
these is a massive understatement nobody
asked for these nobody wants these what
are you doing and then the thing is I
know what they're doing they they need
to give some insurance to their bosses
and to their investors that we have a
plan here's what it is
and
need to be able to present this stuff
and act like they know what they're
doing just digs the hole deeper
if venom is not a massive hit
if venom is not a six hundred million
dollar film there gonna be a lot in a
lot of trouble and that might be part of
why they're talking about making a pg-13
is maybe they know how much is riding on
it and often times pg-13 makes better
than are I suspect the only reason they
stuck with art for so long was the
Deadpool head of course Deadpool is our
for completely different reasons that
venom would be but this is this is I'm
watching a train wreck I mean I'm not
even talking about the film's Sony as a
company right now is just tumbling off
the track and just parts and gears and
bits are flying off willy-nilly and
betting themselves in trees it's
fascinating to watch but it's kind of
depressing so let just news about what
Sony's up to cuz they're mad what are
your thoughts on it whatever they are
drop something down the comments let's
talk about it there's all this stuff to
do you know what it is links for the
stuff is down below I do have a patreon
that's kind of the big one but it's all
down there so just to remember folks you
are the council I just run the meetings
so until next time this council is a
jerk
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]